joining me now is chang-geun da himself
welcome mr. Dundee are now the Turkish
president Richard I'm Edwin says you're
a traitor you're a spy and even a
terrorist your response my responses
he's a lawyer because there's nothing
there's no journalist in jail with these
terrorist charges I mean they are all
convicted or blamed of releasing state
secrets rioting against the government's
being critical about the government's
policies etc so they are just
journalists not the terrorists but
blaming that for terrorism is a kind of
[Music]
traditional attitude of this government
unfortunately their reports that your
personal security has become an issue
since the recent visit by Edwin to
Germany what can you tell us about that
about this the security issue that's
right mm-hmm myself you mean that's
right general know your security I'm
afraid and it's not only me but the
whole opponents of hairdo honors on the
risk everywhere in the world because
everybody watched the press conference
and you can easily see how angry is
against the journalists was critical
about him and he's you know looking for
a revenge and that's why of course you
have to be careful while you are
challenging him so there is no
opposition left almost in Turkey in the
media sector so that's why he is trying
to punish the journalists outside Turkey
just to give the message to the others
that he can find you everywhere so we
are of course keep on struggling but of
course we have to be careful about the
security in Abidjan under after what
happened at the press conference do you
feel more
risk now of course imagine that's one
president is coming to a country and
blaming a journalist for being a spy or
terrorists so what would he expect out
of this there are a lot of people wants
to be a hero in the eyes of him or his
government by punishing the journalists
and we have experienced this in Turkey
and just in front of the courthouse I
was attacked by a gunman and he is just
freed last week without any punishment
so it's a kind of encouragement if
you're not punishing a guy just putting
a gun or a journalist that's the kind of
encouragement of course now a wife still
lives in Turkey are you concerned about
her safety oh yeah of course
I mean it's she is like a hostage and
without any reason and one's keeping her
in Turkey just to punish me and of
course as everybody Shh her life is also
under risk but this is the this is the
unlawfulness that we are trying to
explain to the words that there's no
rule of law with just the system in take
anymore and under these circumstances
you can do nothing but struggle now you
are living here in exile in Germany do
you think the German government is
dealing with the increasingly
authoritarian erawan a regime in the
right way was it for example right to
offer a mistake visit recently as you
know I mean from the beginning I've been
criticizing the German government being
not enough was doing not enough and
saying not enough against Turkey but in
during this visit I guess they were much
more vocal about the injustice system
and the aggression of the Turkish
government the state visit of course was
a question but you have to divide
everyone from Turkey and you have to
respect Turkey and Turkish people while
you have to warn the aired on government
for its crackdown against media so the
test is that division is very important
because you have to be side by side with
people
Turkish people fighting against everyone
and you don't have to isolate them this
is a very difficult balance to build up
but I guess the state visits idea was a
respect to Turkish people and to in
general Turkish nation but at the same
time they were brave enough to gave the
right messages to everyone now you too
attention to many many journalists in
Turkey who are still incarcerated who
are in jail how difficult is it a full
press freedom in the country are you in
contact with some of your former
colleagues of course they are putting
their lives in risk while they are
writing or talking and even today I mean
one of my colleagues and a
parliamentarian at the moment in in
front of the judge together with my wife
for me for for what for a story we
published in every newspaper which was a
true story
nobody denied it and we were accused of
being helpful to the terrorist
organization and ironically we bring
criticizing the government for aiding
and abetting some Islamist guerillas in
Syrian
Syrian borders and now we were accused
of being terrorists or aiding the
terrorist organizations so it is a
witch-hunt against the journalists in
Turkey - to suppress them to stop them
talking or writing but thanks God we
have still brave journalists to search
for the truth right Jan Duda thank you
very much for sharing your thoughts with
DW thank you